hi i'm dr vip patel a professor of
urology at
ucf uh school of medicine and also
medical director of urologic oncology
i'll be giving a talk about
robotic radical prostatectomy
so here i've shared my screen and i was
asked to talk really about our
experience uh over the last 18 years
in terms of prostatectomy in the endless
learning curve
and all the different tips and tricks
that we've learned along the way
the first prostatectomies were done
basically back in 1999 and now we did
our initial cases in 2002
but i have to say what we started as our
goal is quite different from what
ended up developing our initial goal was
to really
just find a different way to do a
prostatectomy that was being done open
or laparoscopically and robots actually
became the perfect combination of
open and laparoscopic techniques and so
i think we've gone well beyond
what we imagined would happen initially
because i didn't think we'd imagine that
90 plus percent of all prostatectomies
would be done with a robot when we first
started
and i think the outcomes have also
supported that and
we've been very pleased with how we've
progressed
as you can see um over the years the
adoptions have changed and
most people in residency fellows and
even
practicing attendings are performing
robotic prostatectomy now
also in terms of if you look at the
national trends in terms of
the market size for medical robotics
as you can see it's still on its upward
curve
and it's quite a large market as we're
seeing medical robotics
start to go into areas outside of
surgery as well
so what have we learned and how did we
learn it i think that's probably the key
question
14 000 cases later we definitely have
had
experience to know what to do and what
not to do and that's what i hope to
share with you today
i think our first win was
we we had a database and we've kept that
database
from the beginning uh to now we
prospectively follow
all of these patients for about 10 years
or so
and we have 300 data points per person
that we collect
and then we follow their outcomes after
surgery we've also published a lot of
our
findings our techniques our tips and
tricks and i think
each of this has been done in an
evidence-based manner and i think that's
the key
if you know what your data shows then
you know
what you've learned and you know what to
teach
our initial goals when we first started
was to make sure we were safe and you
have to remember this was back in the
open air of surgery and there was a lot
of skepticism around laparoscopy and
robotics for sure
and i think most people thought it was a
fad at the time
however we saw some merit in the robotic
technology
providing superiority over
both open and laparoscopic surgery and
so we embarked upon our program
our initial goal was to make sure the
complication rates were low
and also that the oncological results
were good
the surrogate marker for oncologic
cure was initially positive margins to
make sure that
we were doing a good job technically and
then we followed these guys for many
many years making sure
we were keeping track of recurrences to
make sure that
in robotics we were not seeing anything
worse than open or laparoscopic
the other thing that we kept a close eye
on was complications
initially the procedures obviously were
long
you know five six hours sometimes in the
first few
and these patients would feel the brunt
of that
and so operative time clearly is
associated with complications
and so we quickly
tried to lower operative times and to
make sure that we weren't
providing any other increased morbidity
or mortality
i think overall our complication rate
was actually quite low uh overall and
we've maintained that
but there's complications never go away
you know it's
the more you operate the more you see in
some ways
and so every now and again you'll see a
post-op lead
usually the most optimal patient of the
day who went great
and just randomly he'll have a bleed
you'll see
still see deep vein thrombosis homo
embolus
ilius and of course uh lymphocyl
formation these are the things that we
see most commonly
and have not really gone away
margins overall have stayed pretty
stable over
over the years we haven't seen any large
spikes
and what's been beneficial in that is
that
you know the oncology of the tumors
we're seeing are much worse now
and will continue to get worse but the
margins have stayed stable
and that's because we've adopted
adjusted our technique
and we've gone from performing more
fullness spurring to more partial nose
sparing as we see the
oncology of the tumor and the amount of
extra capsular extension getting worse
so it's been a decade almost two decades
now of evolving this technique
and amassing the knowledge from these
patients
i think these are some of the technical
modifications that we've performed
over the years as we operate
as we change things we always keep in
mind the complications
the positive surgical margins and
obviously the trifecta and the
pent-effect outcomes
and here you see some of the techniques
that we have
incorporated into our procedure over the
years
the majority of these are still a key
part of our surgical technique
and each of these was done in an
evidence-based manner
making sure that we followed these
patients we looked at the data
and we analyzed them academically and
then we published them
urinary continence this was one of the
first things we looked at to see if
robotically laparoscopically we could uh
get our our recovery uh back
faster my bladder neck reconstruction
our suspension step
stitch and our posterior reconstruction
called the rocker stitch were all
parts of our operation and when we
incorporated them along the way
and we've published the data showing the
influence
urinary continence i always say is
predictably unpredictable
and uh it's it's harder to predict the
most things
you could have the the worst medical
candidate and obese patient
and they could be dry you know day one
and then you can have a triathlete to
super fit and
they can take six to 12 weeks and a lot
of this is related to the pelvic floor
and the operation the good thing is
um at one year most of the results are
quite good published in the literature
continence rates are very very good
it's really the short-term continents
that is
somewhat variable
these are some of the key continence
mechanisms
that are responsible for urinary
continence and these are some of the
things that we actually
cut or destroyed during prostatectomy
and so
i think it's important to notice and
know
the key structures and what's disrupted
during prostatectomy
because then you can actually
reconstruct and put these things back
together
so that your long-term continence and
your long-term pelvic floor
is is sort of suitable for continents
our suspension stitch is uh being still
used by by most and
basically what it does is it
recreates the pupil prosthetics uh the
pupil prosthetics and pupil urethrals
are often
sacrificed during prostatectomy and this
basically suspends it up to the pubic
bone and allows you to
cut your dorsal vein which it ligates
and it keeps the suspension keeps the
anterior urethra suspended
and we showed that there was an
improvement in early continence using
this
posterior reconstruction was started by
bernardo rocco his father
and we modified it for robotic surgery
together
and this has become a staple of our
surgical procedure it provides good
hemostasis
it approximates the tissue it brings the
bladder down
very nicely and so it makes the
anastomosis easier as well
so this is a key part of our procedure
and i think it's very important
and it's also obviously helpful
incontinence
this is how our procedure really looks
these days
we've decided to do on patients who
don't have anterior tumors apical tumors
we've decided to do a modified apical
dissection
whereby the apical complex and the
public prosthetics are minimally
disturbed and i think that keeps the
urethra suspended and attached
to the lateral ligaments and then when
we're doing a full nose sprayer on a low
risk patient
we do a lateral prostatic fracture
dissection where the lara prosthetic
fascia is still left
on the patient and therefore obviously
the nerve bundles are
also left intact and so this is how it
looks
today one of the key parts to doing this
different kind of apical dissection is
you're
not going as far back on the public
prosthetics
and so you're less likely to
get these vessels that are coming in and
innovating the sphincter
and you're being a little bit more
precise on how you
ligate the tissue and so you're going to
have less
issues with vasculature coming into the
urethra and potentially re
devastating the urethra or the um
the pelvic floor
here's another very important thing as
you can see the prostate is removed the
nerve bundles are down there very deep
you can see them here
and then as you come back you can see
two large
accessory pudendal arteries and these
are important
they are quite large on both sides they
should be saved
because they provide a large portion of
the blood supply to the corpora
so if you do a great nose spraying but
you ligate these arteries
there's a good chance we're going to get
vasculogenic impotence on top of
the neuroproxy from the surgery
so i think the prostate to me really is
an anatomical neurosurgical
operation in many ways as you have
key nerves and vasculature all
intimately involved with the prostate
and so i think the key is how we've
evolved our technique
to preserve the nerves during robotic
prostatectomy
as you can see here this is one of the
welsh diagrams and it shows the arteries
and the veins and where the
the vesicle plexus is in relation to the
neurovascular bundle
and the rectum and what you can see is
right at the base of the prostate the um
the nerve bundle is
intimately um intact with the prostate
capsule
and so when you're saving these nerves
you have to
basically peel them off the prostate
capsule and this becomes obviously a
challenge in bigger tumors and if they
have extra capsular extension
also in low volume disease you want to
stay out of the capsule
making sure you don't leave any
prostatic tissue and
also not cause any positive surgical
margins
so i think neurovascular bundle
preservation is is the challenge
and it's it's what we do
it can be transected it can be crushed
it can be
burned and it can be stretched and so
traction injury is important
you know you can do the most perfect
nerve spuring in the world the prostate
looks great the nerve bundle looks great
but if you caused a lot of trauma from
traction
um you're going to have a neuroproxima
and that's going to lead to some issues
in recovery of potency so
it's very important not only to
technically save the bundle but not to
damage it as you're
saving it and so i think
an a thermal dissection minimizing the
traction making sure that we
save the full bundle from base to apex
is very important but obviously it's
easier said than done
the neurovascular bundle preservation i
think still is
difficult for most surgeons and is still
a challenge for us
and i think our techniques are looking
at trying to
basically extract the bundle away from
the prostate in the least
damaging manner and that's important
but what's also important is that you
know not all nodes are meant to be
spared or not all
neurovascular bundle portions are
supposed to be spared
because of the oncology of the tumor
there are times when these
cancers do go through the capsule and
where do they go they go right to the
neurovascular bundle
and so sometimes a partial nerve sparing
is better for the patient than a full
left bearing
so this is how we like to do our
procedure
making sure we save the whole nerve
bundle from the
apex to the base preserving the
accessory structures
the fascial attachments apricol and
lateral attachments
and then to minimize traction and
coagulation
and to do a good nurse bearing without
destroying other things
and we like to do it also in a
retrograde great manner
and what we mean here is we do an
antigrade prostatectomy
we like to really release the nerve
bundle from below
and then actually go anterior and get in
between the plane of the
prostate and nerve bone and go
retrograde all the way to the base of
the prostate
and then place the clips to free the
prostate
what this does is it gives us a better
plane to get
that fully the full nerve bundle exposed
and dissected and it also prevents us
from
getting into those big veins and
arteries that are anterior
on the prostate capsule
so this is what we'd like to see at the
end the prostate's removed you have a
nice urethra
and you have what we call these train
tracks here
basically these are neurovascular
bundles with arteries veins
nerves on each side of the prostate and
they've been released and the prostate's
been extracted
this is a video here where underneath
the prostate the some of the vesicles in
the prostate are up
neurovascular bundle here is being
dissected on the right side the rectum
is down
and what we're doing is with 30 degree
up lens
uh we're basically getting into that
nice plane between the prostate
capsule and the prostate fascia in the
lateral prostatic fascia the goal is
basically to
get in between them into that nicely
vascular plane
and to go anteriorly up the prostate
and therefore it will make us easier to
do the dissection when we go anterior
and so we do this on both sides
obviously the nerve bundles are on both
sides and they both
need to be preserved and so you do this
on a patient who's
low risk someone who is
has disease that is amenable for a good
nurse bearing
procedure so here you can see we've
done the 30 degree upper section
now we go ahead and switch and we'll go
30 degree down
and we'll do our anterior dissection and
the goal is to try and connect the two
um we've done it here you can see the
nerve bundle is fully exposed and
dissected off of the prostate and then
what we do is we come in a retrograde
manner
and come all the way down to the pedicle
and the base of the prostate the reason
this is important is
is the fact that the prostate's attached
prevents us from getting too much
traction on the nerve bundles
and it keeps them in place also at the
base of the prostate look how close that
nerve bundle is
to the um to the
base of the prostate and the pedicle and
so the only way to truly know where it
is
is to first dissect off the nerve
bundles and then at the base of the
prostate put those clips very very
specifically in the right place
and that's where the retrogradeness
where it really helps make a difference
here
you can see the train tracks right here
but our technical approach has still
evolved
to a different level i think now and and
what we do is
instead of just releasing those nerve
bundles
we now try to leave the lateral
prosthetic fascia
intact on the patient's side and what
that does is
it gives you a new plane that is
closer to the prostate marginally
but the nerve bundles the lateral we
don't see the train tracks anymore
because they're buried behind a lot of
prosthetic fascia and therefore
our belief is that by doing that we're
less likely to touch the nerve bundle
because we don't see it
we're more likely to preserve it fully
and we're less likely to cause traction
and trauma because it's all lateral to
our working field and so we recently
published this
and what we're showing is an earlier
return of consonance and potency in our
patients
so as you can see on the left here this
is the traditional train tracks
but on the right you don't see them at
all not because there's no nerf bundles
there but because they're buried
behind the lateral prosthetic fascia you
can see you don't see the levators the
same way
you just basically see a cavity and that
cavity is lined by the prosthetic fascia
so here once again we have a uh
the seminal vesicles are up the rectum
is down
we've gone 30 degree up again with the
camera
and we're going to basically drop the
rectum dropped an envious fascia off of
the prostate
and get into this nice plane and you can
see the tissue layers of the fascia
peeling off that's the lateral prostatic
fascia
that's attached to the prostate and our
goal is basically to peel that off
and to leave the nerve bundles lateral
you don't even see the nerve bundles
here because they're buried behind this
fascial layer
and therefore i think they're less
likely to be traumatized we do the same
thing on both sides
and then once again we'll go anterior
and i'll show you that
now
and so we've done the dissection
posteriorly and now actually you can see
we're much more medial
the endopelvic fascia is intact there
laterally
we don't see the levators and so this is
a low risk patient
obviously we're trying to do a high-end
nerve sparing here
this is not for all patients but
definitely for low risk patients and you
see that the
left side so the right side here looks
different you don't see the levators you
see we haven't opened that fascia
there's less traction less trauma
because everything's attached
and we can see that the nerve bundles
are not visible
anymore here at the end of the video we
actually show this fascial layer nicely
we can see here that
no train tracks no nerve bundles are
visible
but we can see that this is where the
fascial layer is
on both sides and then we'll grab it so
this is the lateral prosthetic fascia
we've gone medial to it and left the
nerve bundled and everything lateral
to that so slightly different
uh technique this is the prosthetic
fascial layer we don't see the levators
anymore but you can see the levators are
lateral to this facial layer and that's
what makes the difference
functional outcomes we've seen a nice
improvement in potency
and incontinence so this is what we're
doing at this time
we didn't see any increase in positive
margin rates which was
very important to us because we are in a
different surgical plane
but we also selected these patients very
very carefully
can we predict who's going to have the
optimal outcome i think that was one of
my
questions to our fellows is you know
what makes a difference in policies
if the surgeon is constant which is me
and
uh you know what what a patient
characteristics make a difference
and and so what we found was that uh
age was a huge influencer the shim score
and the um the type of nerve spurring so
the shim's pre-option score was the most
important uh if there were good potency
before and they had a tumor amenable to
a nerve spurring
they just did very very well age was
second most
important followed by the actual
technical part of the nerve sparing
these were all very very important
factors for us
full nerve spearing had better outcomes
than a partial that makes sense
but with everything else constant shin
score was important followed by
age you can see here the effect of
different types of nerve spurring a full
versus a intermediate versus a non
makes a pretty big difference our
non-nerve spurring
was some type of nerve sprain we just
said it was less than 50 percent of the
bundle
based on our opinion so that's why you
have a little bit of potency there
is some patients especially younger ones
you can take half the nerve bundles
and they can still come back
the key factor factors age shim score
type of nerve spurring was
was very very important um
patients of all ages with no ed and a
fullness bearing
had excellent potency results so what
you can say is
even if patients are older if they are
amenable to a
good nurse fare oncologically you should
save the nerves because
regardless of age they can still come
back obviously the younger guys come
back
faster and more more often but the old
patients they can still be fine
so what it tells us really is that if
you get optimal patients
uh the the trifecta is very possible
and i think we found that with our
experience there are certain patients we
we're just going to have good results
because they're younger
they have less disease so they could
amendable for a fullness pair
and that's what we're able to do and the
shim scores are good
and so when we looked at our optimal
patients
we found that the trifecta outcomes
were very good in these patients
but there is a challenge there you know
it's the oncology of the tumor has
changed we are seeing
more high risk disease more extra
capsular extension
and so this can be a challenge when
you're looking at
potency results and nurse sparing and
not all nerves are meant to be saved
some people you know more than 50 of our
patients now
have extra capsular extension of some
sort and therefore
the the nerve bundles are are at risk
and so we have to balance the uh the
oncologic versus the
the potency part of the operation
this is what we've seen from from my my
first cases at celebration in orlando to
now
each year we see more and more high risk
patients t3 or more
and that trend
seems to be continuing
so when we look back at our patients
we're seeing that
all the negative parts of the pathology
are increasing
such as similar less global invasion
lymphovascular invasion
extra prostatic extension
and so we actually looked at this to see
what's going on and we looked
at the cut point of 2012 we looked at
patients before and after that
and the reason we used 2012 was that's
when the u.s preventative task force
recommended against psa screening and so
obviously we saw
a change in the type of patient
coming to see us after that after 2012
more active surveillance so those
patients weren't coming to us
but overall the aggressiveness of the
disease has definitely changed
and so what we're finding is that uh
there's definitely a change in patients
that are coming to us changes in
referral patterns
and obviously our experiences increased
as well and what we found is that
after 2012 the aggressiveness of the
disease was more
and what was presenting to us and what
we were seeing in the post-op pathology
there was definitely an increase in
adverse pathology um
decreasing the amount of fullness
spurring and that was a response to the
adverse pathology we're seeing people
with bulky tumors
extension on mri clinically t2 disease
we were just seeing much more high-risk
patients
than we were before 2012. and so
in response to keep our margins
appropriate and our
recurrence rates low we had to adjust
our noseberry
to match that
and so after 2012 there has been a
increase in the rate of
unfavorable pathologic characteristics
there's less fullness spraying there's
less
optimal candidates for our operation and
so
we do just as many partial nose bearings
as we do full nurse bearings
it's all based upon the tumor
so the question next is you we we saw
how to do a fullness spring you know how
do you do a partial
and especially if you're cutting into a
neurovascular structure um isn't
it an all-or-nothing thing and i guess
the answer is no you you can't do a
partial nose spraying and you can do it
well but you do have to be careful and
you do have to have some good experience
to do that
so this is a paper we wrote about the
all or none
concept of nerve spurring is gone now
it's more about
graded types of nerve spurring between
100 25 50
75 there is a variability in terms of
nurse bearing
in order to do that we first had to
figure out how to know
how much disease is outside of the
prostate where
when we looked at the nomograms we were
using such as the partner nomogram
it would tell us the chance of extra
capture extension for a patient but not
the
side it was going to be out or the
location or the amount
and so that wasn't quite helpful you
know
we didn't want to do a wide restriction
on every patient who had a chance of
extra capsule extension
because the majority of it was one
millimeter two millimeters
um and so we had to come up with a
different model and so with the
bernardo's rocco's group in italy we
took twelve thousand lobes of prostate
and analyzed them for extra capture
extension
and then came up with our own
nomogram to predict extra capsular
extension
site specific and the amount
so you can see here this patient left
lobe
has disease but it's relatively low
volume
and so you can do a full nose pair here
everything is green
whereas on the right side here you see
that you have to go at least two
millimeters out
otherwise you're in a chance for getting
the positive margin because of the
location of the extra capsule extension
here
on the right mid and base
and so you can look online the pressy
nomogram
you can plug your data in and you should
do this in all the patients before
surgery
so you know the risk of exercise
extension in these patients
so once you know how much
extra capsular extension and where it's
going to be
how do you translate into surgery the
ability to know
where the structures are and how much
you're taking and so
we we presented that to one of our
fellows dr
shetloff and um we asked him to analyze
how we were doing the nerve spurring
then we actually had the pathologist
also
corroborate that what we found is we
were using certain
anatomical landmarks to save the nerves
and
our pathologist was saying that we were
relatively accurate when we were saving
100 percent
50 percent 75 percent as he looked at
the specimens
but i think the anatomical landmarks and
the
surgical planes were key and what we
found is there
are certain vessels coming off the
prostate and there's a prostatic artery
and these arteries are very common in
the neurovascular bundle on both sides
we were using them as landmarks to
really say what part of extension or
what part
we were saving so here
this is the right side of the prostate
you can see there's an antrimedia artery
a posterior medial artery and a lateral
artery and you have to be medial to all
of those vessels
in order to get a full nose pair if you
start to take those vessels
you start to do more of a partial nerve
spurring instead of a fullness bearing
and we found that if the medial vessels
here were taken
in up to 50 of the nerve bundle was
compromised
on histological exam
so here's your posterior medial artery
we're looking 30 degree up on the
underside of the prostate
and you can see here it's a pretty
robust artery
if you're medial to that you're in the
plane for a full
nerve spurring on that side whereas if
you're lateral to that you're probably
going to take about 50 percent of the
neurovascular bundle
in cases like this where you have
extension outside the prostate
you're going to do a aggressive partial
nurse bearing
and what we found is if you're lateral
to these vessels you have at least a
three millimeter clearance
from the capsule what's important here
is um
at least 85 percent of extra capture
extension is within three millimeters of
the prostate capsule
and so these arteries are important and
can help
oncologically
so here we can see that the artery is
intact there it's on the prostate we've
gone medial to it so we've gone lateral
to it
and but you can still see there's a good
portion of the neurovascular bundle
there
and probably you know in this case 50 to
75 percent of neurovascular bundle is
still preserved and intact
but we do have some cushion on the
lateral border of the prostate
because it's still covered by the artery
the fascia
and therefore that allows us to get a
negative margin
uh but still doing a partial nose
bearing and still leaving plenty of
nerve tissue behind
so so these are some of our our key tips
and tricks
as you can see
14 000 cases later the learning curve is
is endless and i think
we continue to learn we continue to
strive to do better
and help our patients
there's no hundred percent in terms of
potency continence or cancer cure
and and they may never be uh during this
era
but i think as technology gets better as
our operation gets better
as we're able to collect the data and
study it better
i think we will have improvements and i
think the next step is really
intraoperative imaging it'll be great to
see these
tumors during surgery and to be able to
um know how close they are to the
capsule
so that we can do these partial nose
bearings um
better and more accurately so i think
that's that's the key here
so i'll stop our share now
so hopefully uh you enjoyed uh
this uh this discussion and
this is our experience with
prostatectomy
from the beginning i think i would say
if you're starting
keep a database follow your outcomes
study other people who have doing these
procedures as well pick a mentor and
follow that technique for quite some
time until you become quite good at it
and then start adding your own nuances
to it
um there's still a long way to go but i
think we've made some great strides
over the last few years and i think we
will continue to improve
thank you so much